delays and cancellations over at
mccarran airport ahead of one of the
biggest weekends in vegas in a very long
time good evening to you thank you for
joining us at six i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez so what is causing
all the fuss well orco mana joining us
now live from the airport with the
answer
denise and brian we've been seeing many
flight delays and even cancellations
throughout the day here at mcgiron
airport just taking a look at these
screens behind me
the arrivals and departures list those
yellow times so that several flights
are still delayed some by as much as two
hours
we're told the reason is because of the
extreme heat
news now has confirmed with the federal
aviation administration spokesperson
that the delays at mccarran are due to
heat and wind
mccarron says the faa has a traffic
management program that's put into place
during extreme weather conditions
that program is causing some arriving
flights to be delayed by an average of
one hour and 33 minutes at mccarran
according to the faa's command center
website and because some arriving
flights are being delayed
departing flights could also be affected
here's the science behind all this in
hot weather conditions the air is less
dense which means planes have a tougher
time pushing down on the air
to produce a lift mccarran tweeting out
this video
showing a plane taking off to the east
of the airport they say when it's really
hot out some of the runways on this side
of the airport
have a downward slope to help gain speed
and lift
in short they're shuffling runways
around to help keep everyone safe now
we've noticed
a larger chunk of the flights impacted
here are with southwest airlines
in a statement the company tells us that
they're quote making operational
adjustments to minimize
both the number of and the duration of
delays for our customers and here's a
tip always a helpful reminder
not just for southwest flyers but also
any airline
to make sure you check with that airline
to see if there are any delays
reporting live tonight at mccarran
international airport orca mana 8 news
now